earlier today a series of explosions
took place in hotels and churches in
Colombo in the gumbo and mattock level
and shrank as an East Coast the churches
were busy with the Easter Sunday
worshipers the hotels with local people
and foreign visitors reports suggest
that several dozen people have been
killed and hundreds injured in these
evil and senseless attacks our prayers
are with all of the victims and with
their families I saw for myself 30 today
how quickly the emergency services took
action our thoughts are with the
hospital and hotel staff the police and
other emergency services and everyone
who is playing a part in the response to
these terrible events we understand that
some British systems were caught in the
blasts but we are unable to say how many
people are or might have been affected
I'm just on my way together with members
of my concealer team - one of the main
hospitals in Colombo where casualties
have been taken if you are affected or
are concerned about someone who you
think might be affected please help us
to help you if you're in sri lanka
please follow instructions given to you
by local authorities and hotel security
staff please follow our travel advice
and keep checking for updates you can
find our advice at WWF govt UK and third
please let your family at home know that
you are safe if you aren't here in
shrinker but do have loved ones
traveling here you are concerned about
please get in touch with them to check
their ok Colombo's International Airport
is currently working however if you are
flying to or from
do check with your airline or travel
agent whether there has been any change
to check-in wolf-like details again our
thoughts are with the hundreds of
innocent people who suffer today and
with their families